while president biden has unveiled a
massive two trillion dollar plan to
rebuild america's
infrastructure he says it's overdue and
will put americans
back americans to work but the plan
faces political pushback from
both sides of the aisle ed o'keefe is at
the white house
ed the president laid this all out in a
speech in pittsburgh what did he say
he sure did adriana good morning he's
calling it big and bold and on paper it
would be the largest federal spending
program
ever there's 600 billion dollars in this
plan for new roads
hundreds of billions of dollars to
revamp the nation's electrical grids
expand internet access and rebuild aging
schools and hospitals
these repairs are an urgent concern a
leading group of engineers gives the
nation's infrastructure
just a c minus that's because 45 percent
of americans
lack access to public transportation on
average there's a water main break
somewhere in the u.s every two minutes
who knew and more than four in ten
bridges in this country are at least 50
years old and in need of repair
mr biden says he would pay for all of
this with higher corporate tax rates and
by imposing new taxes
on multinational companies moves
republicans have already criticized
meanwhile a group of liberal democrats
is telling the white house
they think this plan isn't big enough
they'd rather see a 10 trillion dollar
plan spent
over the next 10 years the president's
new plan will be the subject of a
cabinet meeting today his first
face-to-face meeting with his cabinet
normally they'd hold this thing in the
white house cabinet room but given the
times
they'll do it at a social distance tony
in the white house east room
all right understandable ed thank you
very much